Now we are going to
answer some fan questions.
Yes.
Is that okay, you ready?
Yes it is.
All right, great.
Firsthand question from
@bennyfactor, on Twitter,
asks, "Do you prefer San
Pellegrino or Perrier
"or some other sparkling mineral water
"that we've never heard of?"
@bennyfactor, on Twitter,
asks what kind of sparkling
water do I prefer.
Well, in fact, benny, the
answer is quite complex.
It differs according to my mood.
I can tell you this.
If I am drinking sparkling
water on it's own,
I might prefer San Pellegrino,
which is an Italian sparkling water.
I like San Pellegrino
under that circumstance.
I could tell you that my
favorite sparkling water
to drink after espresso is
the German Gerolsteiner water,
which is quite a freak of nature.
The mineral content is so incredibly high,
over 2,000 parts per million
total dissolved solids,
also known as TDS and the
mineral content is so high,
in fact, that if you were
to drink a Liter of it a day
you would have a quarter
of your daily requirement of magnesium.
And magnesium is a very
difficult mineral to obtain.
Supplementing orally is inefficient.
I rub magnesium lotion all over my body
to make use of transdermal absorption.
People don't understand;
sometimes they use
artificial products that
they rub on their skin,
like certain sunscreens
and lotions and they say,
"It's okay, I'm not eating
it, it's on my skin",
but whatever you put on your skin
goes into your bloodstream.
For example, people wearing nicotine patch
and other medication patches for a
very direct absorption to the bloodstream.
For example, cavemen used to
swim in the ocean all the time
and the ocean is a rich
source of magnesium.
That transdermal exposure
gave the cavemen the
magnesium they needed.
Now swimming in the ocean
has fallen out of favor
for most of us and therefore
other methods are necessary.
Organ meats have also fallen out of favor,
another rich dietary source of magnesium.
Nevertheless, Gerolsteiner, to me,
has such a dense minerality
that perfectly suits
the bitter complexity that you get
from drinking an espresso.
Wow, okay, do you just
get it from the internet.?
The great thing about Gerolsteiner
is it's so readily available.
It can be found at
every Trader Joe's store
that I've been to.
It can be found at Whole Foods.
I think it costs $1.49 at Trader
Joe, $1.69 at whole foods.
Oh my God.
However, if you buy a
case of Gerolsteiner water
at Whole Foods they
give you anunadvertised
10% case discount, bringing the price down
17 cents per Liter.